well it's really no secret that las
vegas is known for its culinary scene
both on and off the strip
but there is another trend that is
sweeping the valley that promises to
make you maybe
set aside your diet christian casadas
exploring some of the most popular latin
inspired bites
joins us in studio with the details
kristen that's right denise well tough
assignment but in all fairness all these
spots
are a must you find them all around the
valley from mexican food
vegan and even something sweet that
owners say business is hot thanks to all
the social media buzz
las vegas is popping for its unique food
scene from fancy restaurants on the
strip
to food trucks but there is another side
you will miss if you're not connected on
social media
people are doing their social media and
working on us that's that's basically
what what is pushing us beeria is making
waves with its variety of plates infused
with mouth-watering flavors
that will have you rolling your r's from
excitement when i first saw it was on
social media
it was on tick tock and i was like
sounds good
one really popular plate for
hangover this is a traditional mexican
dish and it's typically made with goats
or beef
and cooked or orniado at low heat for
hours and then served as a soup or tacos
which have taken off on social media and
according to this poppin spot on
maryland parkway and sahara
they can't seem to keep up with demand
thanks to social media this mexican dish
is now trending and sparking new ways to
enjoy it
we got video tacos we got tortoise i've
been here like four times
it's really good yeah it's amazing but
not everything that's blowing up online
has
meat the vegan scene like pancho's vegan
tacos promises the same great taste
minus the beef it's all about the
flavors the authentic flavors that we
give you
so you don't miss those flavors but
you're also eating well without even
knowing vegan tacos are nothing new but
how about vegan posole and enchiladas
that this owner says will confuse your
palate but not your appetite
our vegan meats are 78 protein
so they're better protein than animal
protein
the theme for this vegas eatery is
traditional with a touch of day of the
dead decor
which the owner says is making them
stand apart
and if they still have room for dessert
why not splurge on one of these el lotes
empolvorados to give the taste
some spice the crazy watermelon topped
with spices and sugars
or strawberries and cream that is like
pure heaven
in every bite this is just a sample from
this mom and pop shop on sahara near
arville that's staying busy throughout
the pandemic we also have like ice
creams and stuff for kids who are not
like craving like the spicy stuff
so for kids like many antojitos in
spanish or little cravings
have been around for years but it's the
social media buzz that has them trending
around las vegas
so it kind of follows like the word of
mouth like oh i heard it was pretty good
we should actually go check it out each
fad has thousands of followers on social
media
despite the pandemic these owners say
business is hot
as soon as they eat it one of the most
first things they do is take a picture
and i'm sure put it on their social
media so
we're glad that it's working
well as you can imagine i had to set my
diet aside for this story now we took a
poll
on what your favorite spot was from
social media and more than half of the
people
say it's pancho's vegan tacos now they
are amazing but my personal favorite
was the viria so overall it's very hard
to pick just one so we put a list of our
favorites on our website
8newsnow.com christian casadas 8 news
now